ah hi guys yeah i i i i'm gonna get
started in just a second but first
i have something that i just wanted to
say
[Music]
so i think i just won the hispanic vote
in florida right that's the way this
works
or as we call it in the woke community
the latin x
vote in florida really exciting stuff
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
okay we're gonna get to all of the
actual news then we'll get to all of the
ridiculous news the actual news involves
peace breaking out in the middle east
the stupa news involves joe biden not
being an
actual person able to say words and also
donald trump deciding it's a great idea
to do a long-form interview with george
stephanopoulos and his cadre of people
who hate donald trump we'll get to all
of that stuff
in just a moment first let us talk about
the fact that there's an enormous amount
of uncertainty in the market right now
you may have noticed things be crazy
things are wild out there and this means
that you want to diversify at least a
little bit
into precious metals i've been telling
you since 2016 to invest in gold if you
had listened to me then you would be a
lot richer now
that was back when gold was 1300 bucks
an ounce now it is hovering around
historic highs
and around the corner is a contentious
presidential election who the hell knows
what else
i mean remember we were in january and
we thought things were volatile then
when the president was getting impeached
yeah yeah good times well if you haven't
reached out to birch gold to diversify
part of your ira or 401k into a precious
metals ira
or just purchase physical gold or silver
from them go ahead and do it today text
ben
247 4747 and get a free information kit
on protecting your savings with gold
listen
i buy gold i trust birch gold i have
been for years they have an a plus
rating with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews give them a
call ask all of your questions get to
know them and then when you feel
comfortable take a little bit of your
money and put it in precious metals text
ben
so 47 47 47 open a precious metals ira
today again
text ben to 47 47 47
to get started okay so before we get to
the actual news of the day
big announcement are you ready for it
big big big big big announcement
so i have been asked 1 000 times over
the past
few years why in the world are you in
california
like why why would daley wire stay in
california i mean this place
has turned into a hell hole all you do
all day long on the show is just
complain about how bad california's been
and the answer was that i've been in
california literally my entire life
except for a three-year stint when i was
at
harvard law school in boston aside from
that i've spent my entire life
in california and i love this state it's
a beautiful state it's a state with a
lot of culture and a lot of fun to it
it's it's a great place in terms of
activities you got the beach nearby you
got disneyland
and then over time it just became a hell
hole
and it has become a hell hole at this
point and so yesterday we here at the
daily wire announced that we are moving
the entire company to nashville so just
yesterday governor jerry brown former
governor of california from
1970 to 1983 and then again from 2011 to
2019.
he said where are you going to go where
are you going to go you can't you know
okay you you say the california's bad
where are you going to go the answer is
we are going to nashville we are taking
the entire company and we are picking up
and we are leaving and we are putting
our headquarters
in nashville okay that is where the
company will now be located we're taking
all 75 of our jobs
and we're taking our tens of millions of
dollars in annual revenue and we are
moving
all of that outside the state of
california and this is specifically and
really only
due to the crappy governance of the
state it is not because
we are foreign to the state again i've
lived here my entire life my business
partner jeremy boring has been here for
20 years
my parents have been here longer than
i've been alive we're not doing it
because we dislike california because we
are newbies because we couldn't take the
heat
anything like that i've been here the
whole time we are leaving because this
place has become
so horribly governed that if you have
the means to get out
and if you have a company relying on you
and if you have employees who are lying
on you
you are going to leave we are but the
tip of the spear we are not the only
ones elon musk has already
decided to leave the state he'll
probably be taking a lot of employees
with him over time
joe rogan has already left the state we
are leaving the state as well
again we are taking 75 employees who are
based in california and we are moving we
have about a hundred employees across
the country
and we are relocating to a state that is
not run like garbage
tennessee and now did my business
partner
and i did jeremy and i and caleb
robinson our other business partners did
we ever think that we were going to be
moving this company
to nashville no otherwise we wouldn't
have built up these big beautiful
studios here in los angeles
and employed a bunch of people in los
angeles and hilariously enough when we
announced this to our employees we
thought okay a lot of people are going
to be very upset about it it turns out
far more of our employees are excited
about leaving
california then would be excited about
staying in california because this place
has become unlivable
not only is the rent too damn high
because of all of the garbage zoning
regulations here
but the quality of life here has
degraded radically
now i'll be honest with you i had a
tough time convincing my wife just to
leave california
okay and to be frank with you i'm gonna
be splitting my time in some different
places not just in nashville but
the fact is that trying to get my wife
to leave california
was not an easy task because she too has
spent a lot of her life in california
she lived in sacramento
and now she lives in la and she's been
in california for a very long time
and over the past two years she's looked
around and she said
okay i guess you're right and the reason
for that is perfectly obvious
between the city of los angeles deciding
that they were going to see the entire
city
to low-level criminality they're not
going to enforce the law they're not
going to keep the streets clean they're
not going to make it livable for me to
allow my children to play outside of our
front gate
without adult supervision between them
allowing the streets to become
incredibly dirty and dangerous because
here's the reality if i let my kids walk
around the neighborhood they will
stumble across two open needles
during the course of that walk because
the city has specifically told law
enforcement they can't do anything about
the rampant homelessness problem that
has plagued los
angeles so 66 000 homeless people in l.a
county every single underpass in l.a
has entire living facilities for
homeless people this is not by the way
sympathy to the homeless many of whom
really need serious help they are drug
addicted or mentally ill
and the city has decided that in the
name of freedom they are going to allow
the suburbs to be overrun
by this homelessness problem that does
affect people who are paying their taxes
and between that between the fact that
they've decided to defund the cops
and move away from allowing the police
to do their jobs entirely
between the increased taxes and the
higher levels of crime
and the lower levels of cleanliness
between the fact that
god decided to plague the state with a
giant wildfire spate over the last
several years apparently
it's like i didn't need the help god
like i got it i got it i didn't need the
signs and the wonders to drive me from
california
and frankly i'm just hoping that when
michael moles looks back at california
as we make our way out that he turns
around he looks back and he immediately
turns into a pillar of salt like that is
my dream but
whether or not that happens we are
leaving and you're going to see more of
this
again you're going to see a lot of this
new york new jersey connecticut you're
going to see this
in la you're going to see this in san
francisco people are going to pick up
and they're going to leave and the
people who are most likely to leave are
the people who can afford
to leave let's be honest about this the
people who are going to get trapped in
los angeles
are the people who are lower middle
class because they don't have the
wherewithal to pick up and leave
they don't get to decide honestly where
their jobs take place
as the head of a company i get to decide
where we take our jobs and we are
excited to allow our people a better
living standard moving to some place
like nashville that is not governed
like garbage in a red state then forcing
them to stay in a place that is very
difficult to raise children and to live
blue states for too long have thought
that they can govern as badly as they
want there will be no consequences
that's true to a point and then beyond
that point it is no longer true
we have reached the breaking point we
are leaving and so daily wire will see
you
in nashville okay now in actual global
news
that matters an awful lot and this is
the stuff that the media are really
downplaying
i mean seriously downplaying this is a
major earth-shattering thing that is
happening
on the foreign policy front and so
naturally the media are focusing on
whatever dumb thing trump retweeted
today
or joe biden being able to string
together about half of a sentence before
nearly physically collapsing the actual
big news of the day
yesterday was that donald trump
facilitated a major middle eastern peace
deal
the media were beside themselves over
this they could not believe it
they cannot believe it's the extent that
they have now been attempting to
downplay
the importance of a peace deal between
israel the united arab emirates
and bahrain okay and and by the way
there are going to be a bunch more
countries that sign on i would assume
that morocco will sign on i assume sudan
will eventually sign on
oman came along as well they were
actually at the signing ceremony
and the end goal eventually will be the
saudi arabian government recognizing the
state of israel which is something that
has never happened
in the media been trying to downplay
this the reason they've been trying to
downplay this is because the entire
peace deal that is emerged in the middle
east
is a direct rebuttal to decades of
received wisdom
in foreign policy circles from morons
like thomas friedman and ben rhodes and
the barack obama administration and the
clinton knights
that received wisdom was israel would
never be able to live in safety and
security unless they made concessions to
palestinian terrorists that
all conflict in the middle east sprang
full-blown
from the conflict between the israelis
and the palestinians and that is a lie
it was always a lie it was never true
the palestinians were merely a club that
was being wielded
by various countries that hate israel in
order to distract their own populations
from the crappy governance in those
countries
and to give them a reason to hate israel
as opposed to looking
to broader concerns now countries that
are looking forward and realizing that
they have to shore up their regimes
countries looking forward and realizing
that there are actual existential
threats that israel does not care about
saudi arabia does not care about the uae
or bahrain is not trying to invade
anyone
that israel just wants to exist in
safety and security those countries are
looking to iran and going oh wait
those guys want to take us over those
guys are interested in harming us
and so they formed a de facto alliance
with israel
and normalized relations were the first
step in that sort of de facto alliance
there will be technology sharing
there will be economic sharing there's
an amazing moment
it's a complete realignment and the
realignment not only happened in spite
of the conventional wisdom which
suggested
that the only way peace would break out
in the middle east is if the united
states pushed israel into concessions
it completely rejected that in fact
peace only broke out in the middle east
because the united states made clear it
was not going to force israel into
concessions the trump administration
by making obvious that israel was going
to be able to
pursue its own foreign policy that
israel is going to be able to strengthen
itself
by moving the embassy to jerusalem which
is a statement that israel's capital is
never going to be given away
it will never be divided a statement
that the golan heights will never be
handed over to syria or any other
country
once the united states made that clear
other countries went okay well i guess
this is just a foregone conclusion
which by the way is what the approach
should be to the palestinian issue as
well
which should be israel is not giving up
any of the settlements it has already
built
that is obvious it is true and once you
accept that and once you accept israel's
existence
and you accept that israel isn't going
away then maybe you can talk about peace
but israel is not going to be swamped by
millions of palestinians who believe
that they should be allowed to live
inside israel proper despite the fact
that they live inside a separate
governed entity called the palestinian
authority or hamas stand in gaza strip
in other words reality is a better
predicate for peace than fantasy
nonsense than utopian garbage that has
been pushed
by democratic and republican
administrations alike up until trump
by setting up a realistic assessment of
what exactly is the truth in the middle
east which is that israel is here to
stay
that israel has certain interests that
is going to pursue
and that other countries have interest
they are going to pursue and that people
don't spend all of their time thinking
about israel
that actually most of the conflict in
the middle east over the last 50 years
has not involved israel
and if you're looking at the biggest
conflicts in the middle east whether
it's the iran iraq war which killed a
million people
or whether you're looking at the gulf
war or gulf war ii whether you're
looking at isis
or whether you're looking at the war in
yemen most of the major conflicts in the
middle east
have been sunni shia conflicts they have
not in fact involved israel at all
which means that maybe there's a lot of
room to make peace and that's what
happened yesterday
is that that became absolutely clear it
rejected
literally decades of received wisdom
from the wisest foreign policy minds and
the wisest foreign policy minds could
not stand it they could not handle it
how could this idiot jared kushner have
solved this problem how could that
donald trump have solved the problem
maybe because they rejected wisdom that
had no evidentiary basis
maybe because they looked at the world
situation and they realized that your
idiotic notions
that jews lay at the center of all the
problems that was actually the problem
maybe they realized that people have
countervailing concerns that actually
affect them in their daily lives
in a certain particular way the received
foreign policy conventional wisdom
it sort of mirrors the sort of robin
angelo anti-racism movement
that they're all these problems in the
world but only white liberals can solve
them
they're systemic racism and evil and all
of america's systems are bad only white
liberals can solve
this was the received wisdom in europe
and in america only the americans could
solve
right sure we had nothing to do with the
middle east really but only we could
solve and only we could solve
by getting the other quote-unquote
european people
and there is this perceived wisdom i
mean this is something barack obama said
that israel was really formed in the
aftermath of world war ii and that was
the connection
now this is still the received wisdom in
europe is that the jews in israel are
sort of expatriate europeans which is
nonsense okay there's been jewish
connection to the land of israel
since the land of israel started to
matter to anyone at any time
okay but that sort of received wisdom
was the predicate for a lot of bad
foreign policy
got a lot of people killed and now peace
is breaking out because that receives
wisdom has been rejected so yesterday
president trump gets up at the white
house
in this historic signing ceremony and he
says we're here to change the course of
history
we're here this afternoon to change the
course of history
after decades of division and conflict
we mark the dawn of a
new middle east thanks to the great
courage of the leaders of these three
countries we take a major stride toward
a future in which people of all faiths
and backgrounds live together in peace
and prosperity
in a few moments these visionary leaders
will sign the first two
peace deals between israel and the
arab state in more than a quarter
century that's kind of a big deal right
you would imagine that lead all of the
newspapers right that would be the chief
headline it is not the top headline at
the new york times it is not the top
headline at the washington post
it is not the top headline at cnn it
just fell out of the news
imagine if barack obama had actually cut
some sort of peace deal the iran deal
was the headline
for weeks for the mainstream media what
a genius diplomatic
was the worst diplomatic move by the way
in modern american history
i mean a horrible move such a horrible
move that it actually created a
countervailing
alliance between israel and the sunni
nations that's how bad the iran move was
in opposition to the united states
backing iran an entire alliance formed
between the jews and the arabs i mean
that's
you got the jews and the arabs on the
same side specifically because barack
obama was such a bad president
understand that that's what happened
here okay we'll get to more of that
historic signing ceremony and why it
matters and why it really is a feather
in the cap of the trump administration
that the media are deliberately ignoring
we'll get to that in a second first
there are a thousand reasons why
protecting your home
matters to you ring has security
products for every corner
of your home inside and out as i've been
mentioning la is degrading and degrading
quickly
and while we may be leaving la we're
still going to put ring devices wherever
we go because the fact is that i'm
always worried about safety and security
at my home
also i have young children i want to be
able to keep an eye on them no matter
where i am because little kids are
little suicide machines they're
constantly trying to kill themselves i
want to make sure
that i know where they are at all times
this is why i love ring with ring you
can keep an eye on your home no matter
where you are directly from your phone
if somebody stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know
it's peace of mind anytime knowing that
your home is protected
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ringgit.com it comes with ring
video doorbell three and time pro it's
the perfect way to start your ring
experience plus
free two-day shipping go to ring.com
that is ring.com go check them out right
now you can see and speak to whoever is
at your door from anywhere with video
doorbells
you can keep an eye on every corner of
your house with easy to install indoor
and outdoor cams you can protect your
whole home with ring alarm a powerful
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself go check
them out right now at ring.com
and get that special offer on the ring
welcome kit with the ring video doorbell
3 and chime pro a great way to get
started
securing your home ring.com okay
president trump also announced yesterday
that this was just the beginning
that nine more nations could join
including apparently saudi arabia
nobody thought of the plan that i
thought of and it's going around the
back door i call it going around the
smart door and coming in a different way
and we have many other countries going
to be joining us and they're going to be
joining us soon
we'll have i can i mean i think seven or
eight or nine we're gonna have a lot of
other countries joining us
including the big ones i spoke with the
king of saudi arabia
at the right time i do think they will
come in yes i do
okay well that would obviously be the
major move and here's the reality
obviously bahrain is not joining this
deal without saudi permission
and even the uae deal saudi has allowed
its airspace to be used for commercial
airliner movement between
the uae and israel trump added we have a
lot more deals like this
you know for for a guy who's been ripped
up and down for not being able to make
deals there's a pretty historic deal is
it not
it's gotten rave reviews even from the
new york times and tom friedman and a
lot of people
that don't like donald trump too much
they've given it literally rave reviews
so
this is one deal but we have many others
like this
look our country's been stagnant for
many years we did nothing but give our
money away give our wealth away
and give our jobs away and now we
stopped that
we stopped that three and a half years
ago okay he is
not wrong about his ability to to make
deals at least in the middle east so
benjamin netanyahu got up and gave a
speech now
another note about the idiotic nature of
our foreign policy media here in the
united states their line has been only
left-wing israeli governments will make
a deal
right left-wing israeli government is
what you need you need conciliatory
submission-based left-wing israeli
governments and bibi netanyahu is evil
he's hilarion
he's fascistic okay now maybe netanyahu
has won a lot of elections
elections and he's been doing it like
every three months because in israel
they love elections so much they just
never stop them
he's been elected like three times in
the span of the last two years because
they could not form a government okay so
bibi netanyahu this horrible
right-winger who happens to be one of
the more historic israeli prime
ministers
in history right i mean just most
important by any stretch of the
imagination
here are the governments that have cut
peace deals okay the governments that
have cut peace deals
have been in order menachem began right
which is a peace deal
by likud with egypt that was a peace
deal
we have seen ariel sharon attempt to cut
a peace deal and by the way engaged in
the gaza withdrawal which was actually a
huge mistake
and now bibi netanyahu it turns out that
right-wing governments are typically
better in israel at making deals than
left-wing governments why because
left-wing governments tend to deal from
a position of weakness right when
governments tend to deal
from a position of strength here is bibi
netanyahu pointing out
that you know while the entire media
seems to think that this is all about
trump it is not this is about
making a better world for people living
in the middle east as a as a person bibi
netanyahu who served in israel's special
forces
and his brother yoni netanyahu was
famously
killed during the ann's hebrew raid and
he talks about how people who have been
wounded
in the in the causes of peace cherish
peace more than anybody else
i am so deeply moved to be here today
for those who bear the wounds of war
cherish the blessings of peace
and the blessings of the peace we make
today
will be enormous
first because this peace will eventually
expand
to include other arab states
and ultimately it can end the
arab israeli conflict once and for all
okay that is i mean this has always been
true by the way israel has always wanted
to make peace with its enemies i mean
there are famous stories of after the
menachem began peace deal with the
egyptians
wounded soldiers from both sides
egyptian soldiers and israeli soldiers
wounded soldiers approaching each other
in the desert and giving each other hugs
because
everybody would like peace at a certain
point so long as it doesn't mean
submitting
to terrorism hey then all the leaders of
these nations sat next to each other
they
they signed this normalization agreement
it's an amazing thing
it is it's an amazing thing you can see
the video of them all signing these
normalization agreements in hebrew and
english
and in arabic right which is an
incredible incredible thing
in dubai at the burj khalifa israel's
national anthem was played
i mean this is incredible stuff israel's
national anthem remember these nations
have not
acknowledged that the jewish state ought
to exist that the
zionist entity ought to exist here is
video
of israel's national anthem being played
at burj khalifa
in dubai
i mean that's pretty amazing okay the
walls of the old city in jerusalem
were lit up yesterday with the flags of
israel the uae and bahrain
right this is in jerusalem the most
contested city in probably world history
and you have a jewish flag and two arab
muslim flags
flying alongside each other on the walls
of the old city of jerusalem
that's an amazing amazing sight so this
historic stuff so how does the media
treat all of this by pretending that
it's not important at all
so vox is aaron rupar who is just a
i mean just
a dud he tweeted out reality check
israel has never gone to war with uae or
bahrain
oh well i guess it doesn't matter then i
guess they were best friends
israel has never gone to war with the
uae or bahrain oh
all right well officially the united the
united states never went to war with the
soviet union
seriously officially there was no war
between the united states and the soviet
union
i guess that if they'd signed some sort
of peace accord then that would have
meant anything
because they were never officially at
war makes perfect sense the united
states has never been officially at war
with china
if we sign some sort of agreement that
radically de-escalated tensions that
probably would be non-historic as well
these people are just i'm sorry
they're so stupid i'm amazed how bad
our foreign policy experts are on these
issues because they literally know
nothing they are dumb as a rock it's
unreal
we'll get to more of the media's
stupidity on this because they
completely blew it
we'll get to more on this in just one
second first let us talk
about the fact that now is not a great
time to visit the auto parts store i
mean
put aside all of the threats inherent in
being in crowded lines
also why would you ever visit an auto
parts store i mean you're going there
and then they have to order the part
online anyway or they give you a generic
part that's not the greatest and then
they overcharge you
this is why you should use the internet
for everything rockauto.com
it's much easier than walking into a
store and someone's demanding quick and
specific answers about your car instead
you can
do this from the quiet and convenience
of your own home and get the best price
on the product
as well like say you happen to need a
delphi fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey
that'll cost you like 354 bucks at a
chain store at rock auto that'll cost
you 217 bucks
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts that rockauto.com
catalog it's unique it's remarkably easy
to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands specif
specifications and prices you prefer
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you go check them out right
now okay so how badly did the media get
this wrong here's just a little bit
of a review of how bad the media blew
this here's a a compendium put together
by the washington free beacon
of various members of the news media
informing us how bad trump's foreign
policy in the middle east was going to
be and how it was going to explode the
entire middle east
oh yeah until peace broke out all over
president trump's big decision to
recognize jerusalem as the capital of
israel and one that palestinians and
others say could destroy
hopes of middle east peace once and for
all the president's unilateral action
will get people killed
how hot will it get and how
destabilizing will it be
what he has done is thrown a diplomatic
bomb into the middle east peace process
they're not interested in history they
don't know history that would then
embarrass
all the sunni arab regimes they would
have to do something
enormously complicated by the way
israel's relations with them it's going
to stop any hope of middle east
progress in the peace talks so all these
geniuses so much geniusing happening
over on msnbc you saw there thomas
friedman the lead in the foreign
policy establishment who wrote a piece
today trying to explain how all this
happened and of course got it completely
wrong and then suggested at the end of
the piece
that all that's going to happen now that
the entire arab world has made clear
that they have no
real interest in helping the palestinian
terrorist leadership gain statehood
thomas friedman's suggestion is well i
guess that'll just put pressure on
israel to actually make concessions to
palestinian terrorists yeah sure thomas
friedman you stupid ass
i mean these are idiots yeah if you move
the embassy to jerusalem the world is
going to burn
moved it to jerusalem nothing happened
if you recognize the golan heights
israeli territory the world will burn
the arab street
nothing happens oh yeah and then the
entire arab world turns on the
palestinians and says you know it seems
like you guys are really intransigent
and terrible by the way thomas friedman
that
he says that the real problem here is
that bibi netanyahu is not
is is too intransigent with regard to
the palestinians
it's just it's unbelievable yeah and
let's not forget in all of this how bad
the obama administration was
obama gets half credit for this he gets
half credit for this because he
inadvertently
created all of the conditions necessary
for the breaking of the impasse between
israel and the sunni states
by deciding to openly side with the
massive terror regime in iran
by shipping them billions of dollars by
opening their economy by giving them a
clear pathway to a nuclear bomb 10 years
from
the signing of the deal which by the way
is fast approaching
barack obama essentially created a de
facto alliance in the middle east
against iran
and against his own interests so you
want to put those idiots in charge of
foreign policy again
how dumb are these people john kerry
said that moving the embassy to
jerusalem would lead to a mideast
explosion
right here's what he said in an
interview with david martin of cbs in
january of 2017.
the question was what would happen if
the united states were to move a
tendency to jerusalem
you'd have an explosion said john kerry
an absolute explosion in the region
not just in the west bank and perhaps
even in israel itself
but throughout the region the arab world
has enormous interest in haram al-sharif
as it is called
the temple mount the dome it is a holy
site for the arab world
and all of a sudden jerusalem is
declared to be the location
of our embassies that have profound
impact
on the readiness of jordan and egypt to
be as supportive as an engaged with
israel as that
yeah the adult the only thing that
the
the obama administration did not lie
about is how pliable the media wore in
favor of the obama administration ben
rose just lied to the media openly about
how iran had moderated
and everybody in the media establishment
including the idiot jeffrey goldberg
swallowed it hook line and synchro and
now they can't get over the fact that
they completely blew it
and this is why you end up with the
media trying to downplay this juan
williams yesterday
i mean i like juan as a person but this
is so stupid juan on fox news yesterday
tried to explain that this entire middle
eastern deal was just a distraction it
was just a distraction you see
why is nancy pelosi calling it a
distraction
well because it is you know this is a
moment when you could look at the
situation and say
the real trouble here is between the
palestinians
and the israelis and that situation has
not been helped
but the real action here is in the
united states giving arms
giving serious arms to uae uh
potentially to go
after the iranians and so what we're
doing is stirring up a proxy war
oh that's what we're doing is starting
up the proxy war has already been there
juan
i'm sorry the centrality of the
israeli-palestinian issue has been
resolved it is not central it has not
been central it is a lie that it ever
was central
and the new york times meanwhile printed
what has to be the dumbest column on
this
called a white house ceremony will
celebrate a diplomatic win and a
campaign gift this is by
geniuses michael crowley and david half
halbinger
leaders of the persian gulf states are
grateful to mr trump who has embraced
their government's crackdown on their
arch nemesis iran and defended them from
intense political criticism
in washington like mr netanyahu they are
eager to see mr trump win a second term
in november and at the white house on
tuesday netanyahu and a select group of
gulf arab officials will be returning
the favor doing their part to repay and
support mr trump oh that's what happened
here
so amazingly enough all it took for
peace to break out in the middle east
is a bunch of people to like trump okay
now in reality
this has very little to do with their
personal relationships with trump and it
has everything to do with the fact that
all of the interests aligned
specifically because democrats
promulgated crappy policy in the middle
east okay so what did the media really
decided to do it
they decided to downplay it so wolf
blitzer has on jared kushner yesterday
jared kushner who was widely mocked as
oh look at this stupid son-in-law of
president trump this real estate guy
he's going to solve peace in the middle
east yes he is going to
start to break it to you gag the answer
was yes jared kushner did a good job
here so did his deputy avi berkowitz
the kushner team was intimately involved
in every aspect of this
every aspect so wolf blitzer has on
jared kushner and what does he do
he grills him over trump's stupid tweets
you have a historic peace process that
breaks out
into an actual signing ceremony at the
white house involving israel and two
muslim arab nations and wolf blitzer is
very focused with jared kushner the
architect of this deal
on why donald trump is tweeting about
hashtag pedobiden
i saw the president retweet to his 80
million plus followers
a very very disturbing ugly message
accusing the the democratic presidential
nominee joe biden of actually being a
pedophile
look well if i haven't seen the tweet
i've been focused today on this historic
peace deal i got here early in the
morning i've been helping get this thing
ready please tell him
tell your father-in-law that it's really
bad it's really disgusting to retweet
those kinds of ugly disgusting tweets
about his democratic
rival well that's really the key issue
here guys let's focus in
on what truly matters right now not a
historic peace deal in the middle east
whatever is the distraction that they
wish to uh that they wish to push today
i'm looking at the new york times front
page right now
here are the headlines okay on the front
page of their website these are the top
headlines
hurricane sally dumps two feet of rain
barely halfway through a hyperactive
hurricane season forecasters are running
out of names what then
big ten will play football in 2020
reversing decision party selfies and
hazmat suits have new york's worst
campus outbreak unfolded
rain could offer some relief for oregon
and washington election update
primary season is finally over on the
fire line grueling work in a shared
purpose
u.s retail sales show slower growth in
august house report condemns boeing and
faa and 737
max disasters why it's almost as though
this didn't happen
because if you read the front page of
the website of the new york times this
didn't happen
okay i'm looking the first headline
about
this peace deal is buried all the way
down
at the very very bottom of the website
only in the like
world news section it's not even the
world news section i'm literally
it's in the politics section it is
buried at the very bottom it's headline
number 83.
imagine if barack obama had done this i
mean not only did they give a nobel
peace prize for literally being in a
live human
they would have given another one for
actually doing something useful they
want to give them a nobel peace prize
for the iran peace deal the worst deal
ever
okay but they got to downplay the whole
thing because obviously trump bad orange
man very very bad bad orange man bad
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
joe biden who continues to babble
nonsensically
his way across the country and then
we'll get to donald trump who decided to
step on what was a triumphant moment at
the white house by doing an ill-advised
interview
on abc i mean first rule of politics
if you're donald trump don't get into a
town hall with like george
stephanopoulos and his band of
of rando questioners who hate your guts
that seems like a bad idea
joe biden was smart enough not to do it
right joe biden was like i don't have
time for that
he he was too busy playing pinup by
himself in the basement
in delaware and we'll get some more of
this in just one second first
it's getting out it's getting unsafe out
there i mean we've seen it breaking out
in la we've seen breaking out in chicago
in new york in washington dc it is just
getting
unsafe out there we've seen people
accosted eating dinner we've seen people
accosted outside their homes we've seen
people walking into suburban
neighborhoods
and trying to tag tag houses it's
getting unsafe out there and this is why
you really need to be a gun owner if
you're a law abiding citizen and not
only that you need to know how to use
that gun
i don't just mean that you need to know
how to operate the gun i mean that you
need to know what you legally can and
cannot do because the fact is that these
days
you could properly use a gun in
self-defense it could still be arrested
for using a gun in self-defense as we
have seen
repeatedly over the last few months in
this day and age you need a gun to
protect your family and yourself and
you need a free 100 free copy of the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide from the us concealed
carry association
it's 164 pages it comes with the bonus
audio version so you can listen whenever
you want just text shapiro to 87222
you'll get instant access and a chance
to win a thousand bucks so you can buy a
gun to protect your family text shapiro
to eighty seven
two two two again that is eighty seven
two two two text shapiro to eighty seven
two two two and you get
a chance to win a thousand bucks you can
buy a gun protect your family and
more importantly a 100 guaranteed free
copy of the complete concealed carry and
family defense guide from the us
concealed carry
association okay as part of our daily
audience announcement
there are a number of ways you can take
in this podcast you can listen on apple
podcast spotify or another podcast app
you can also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook or over at
dailywire.com here's the bottom line
we're making our content available to
you anywhere you watch or listen
and now we are introducing a new
upgraded experience
daily wire is now on apple tv and roku
so members can enjoy all of the visual
elements on this podcast on your big
screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wear on apple tv or roku and download
today you have to be an insider member
to watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com
shapiro use code watch at checkout to
get 15 off your membership purchase
the deal is not going to last long so
act fast if you want live shows on your
big screen
plus the one of a kind highly coveted
never duplicated
often imitated leftist years tumblr
again that is dailywire.com to get 15
off with codewatch and download the
daily wire on your apple tv and roku
today also quick reminder if you are
watching this on youtube
right now you should head on over to the
ben shapiro youtube channel because
starting at the end of september
we are going to be shifting all of these
broadcasts over to just that channel you
can't just subscribe at daily wire at
youtube
and then get the show you actually have
to go over to the ben shapiro channel
and subscribe so pause whatever you're
doing right now head over there just hit
the little bell
and then you will be subscribed over
there you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so president trump had a good
day
for most of the day and then he did this
town hall with
with abc now i don't i wonder what the
strategic
idea here was i assume the strategic
idea here is to get trump out as often
as possible
to highlight the fact that joe biden
refuses to be asked any tough questions
and it's a strategy but i don't think
that trump actually needs to prove that
people understand he has energy
in fact one of the knocks on trump is
that he may not is that he may have too
much energy because
he can't sit still is that he's up at 3
30 in the morning sitting on the toilet
and tweeting out fox and friends right
that is one of the big critiques
of president trump so we don't actually
need more president trump at this point
the president needs to sit down and he
needs to be quiet and need to let joe
biden
be the focus of the campaign more biden
less trump is a recipe for biden losing
more trump and less biden is a recipe
for trump losing okay but trump does
this town hall
on abc news last night and again why you
would do this with george stepanopoulos
it is a source of constant amazement and
astonishment to me
that george stephanopoulos is considered
an objective news anchor it's like karl
rove
being considered an objective news
anchor now carl would never
proclaim himself such george
stephanopoulos has the man literally
wrote in his book about
weeping backstage with hillary clinton
the night that bill clinton won the
presidency in 92.
his george stephanopoulos is a
clintonista
he was on i believe is the cover of time
magazine with bill clinton
like the idea that that guy's an
objective news anchor just demonstrates
how ridiculous our mainstream media are
so trump never should have done this
and his media people honestly should be
ashamed of themselves for putting trump
in this situation
and then trump demonstrated that he
didn't prep it really was not a
particularly good showing
and again let the headline be the
headline the headline is you just made a
major peace deal in the middle east let
that headline
be the headline instead he goes on abc
news and the thing was stacked
i mean there's no question that thing
was stacked what i mean by that is that
you didn't see a lot of questions about
you know president trump hear all the
wonderful things you did can you explain
them
now every question to biden would be
that right every question would be joe
biden
you're such a compassionate wonderful
man explain to me how compassionate and
wonderful you are and how bad your
opponent is
every question for trump of course was
why are you a racist why don't you care
about people like me dying
so for example a black pastor was uh was
brought forth
to ask the president why his slogan make
america great again is racist like this
is an actual question asked at a town
hall
you've coined the phrase make america
great again
when has america been great for african
americans in the ghetto of america
are you aware how tone deaf that comes
off to african american community
if you look at just prior to and i'm
talking about for the black community
you look just prior to this horrible
situation coming in
from china when the virus came in that
was the probably
the highest point home ownership for the
black community
home ownership uh lower crime
the best jobs they've had highest income
okay so he immediately swivels to of
course his economic performance but
that basic question and there's a good
answer to it which is
america has historically fallen short
for black americans but the principles
upon which america was built
provided the pathway toward more freedom
and prosperity for black americans than
any ethnically black people on the
planet
which happens to be the truth okay but
in any case
forget about what trump's answer is the
fact that he walked directly into
a scenario like this is not particularly
smart politics okay here's another
question asked by a quote-unquote trump
voters so here is a a
supposed trump voter who is angry at
trump he says why did you throw people
like me under the bus if you believe
that joe biden would ever receive a
question like this in a mainstream media
setting it's because you're high
i voted for you in 2016. i'm
conservative pro-life
and diabetic i have had to dodge people
who don't care about
social distancing and wearing face masks
i thought you were doing a good job with
a pandemic response
until about may 1st then you took your
foot off the gas pedal
why did you throw vulnerable people like
me under the bus
well we really didn't pull we've worked
very hard on the uh pandemic
we've worked very hard honestly why did
you throw vulnerable people like me
under the bus what does that mean
throw vulnerable people like you under
the bus and what specifically is the
question there
so again trump you know shouldn't have
done this particular
town hall it is not smart you don't need
more of them out there there's plenty of
donald trump out there i don't think
anybody has a shortage of donald trump
if we were looking at like shortages on
the menu this is not one of them there
is plenty of that in the back
right we've got plenty of trump in the
back there's plenty more where that
comes from
and then of course you had the typical
kind of trump bachelors right so you had
trump being asked about face masks
and he specifically asked about it and
instead uh and he says face masks
are kind of controversial the evidence
on them is split and then instead of
citing the actual evidence being split
which it kind of is right i mean most of
northern europe scandinavia
they are not masking up the health
officials in those countries have said
that masking asymptomatic people
is actually a waste of time and or
counterproductive that social distancing
is more important
instead of talking about the fact that
the who until five minutes ago was a big
proponent of not masking up when you
were asymptomatic
instead the president decided he was
going to randomly talk about waiters and
touching their faces and stuff now i
think the point that he's trying to make
here to
to try and be charitable the point that
he's trying to make here is that if you
improperly wear a mask it is actually
counterproductive that happens to be
true
okay my wife when she was in medical
school they actually give you
a class in how to use ppe right how to
properly wear a mask
because one of the problems is if you're
constantly messing around with your mask
with your hands
then you actually get the germs from
your hands on the outside of the mask
you breathe that in
right or the germans that have accreted
to the outside of the mass you get them
on your hands and later when you rub
your nose you end up
so they're they're problems if you
improperly wear a mask but overall
in crowded areas are masks a good idea
yeah they are i mean because
if you sneeze in a crowded area the mass
block blocks must in any case here was
trump going off on waiters or something
a lot of people don't want to wear masks
there are a lot of people think the
masks are not good
and there are a lot of people that as an
example you have those people
i'll tell you who those people are
waiters they come over and they serve
you and they have a mask and i saw it
the other day where they were serving me
and they're playing with the mask i'm
not blaming that i'm just saying what
happens
they're playing with a mask so the mask
is over and they're
touching it and put and then they're
touching the plate that can't be good
okay so again is this useful stuff no it
is not useful stuff
and then trump hit biden on the mask
mandate the point he's trying to make
here is that joe biden says that he's
gonna mandate masks but he actually has
no intention of doing anything
along those lines so he's kind of lying
to you right he says he's going to mask
everybody he has no power to do it he
himself has said that
but again stephanopoulos tries to get
push trump into basically
suggesting that biden has the power to
mandate masks right now
it's very silly
well i do wear them when i have to and
when i'm in hospitals and other
locations but i will say this
they said at the democrat convention
they're going to do a national mandate
they never did it because they've
checked out and they didn't do it
and a que a good question is you ask
like joe biden they said we're going to
do a
national mandate on mass it's called on
all governors to have them it is a
statement
but he didn't do it i mean he never did
it okay and so biden immediately said
well
uh i can't do it i'm not the president
well even if you're the president you
can't do it
right in any case was this a good idea
for trump on a day of
foreign policy triumph no this is a bad
idea for trump now here's the thing i
think most of this is baked in
just politically speaking just putting
on the analyst hat most of this is baked
in when i say most of them nearly all of
it
people know who trump is they believe
what they're going to believe about
trump the person
who still has play in his numbers is
biden so biden's numbers have been
pretty stable throughout
but biden is one falling off the stage
bob dole 1996 moment
from his numbers cratering because the
fact is
that joe biden is not with it he is not
and i know that that's a lot for for
trump to gamble on right trump is
basically gambling on a couple of things
at this point
one that the american people will wake
to the fact that the democratic party
has moved in an incredibly radical
direction
and two that joe by the american people
would believe that joe biden being
unhealthy means that kamala harris will
be president
and frankly biden and harris have been
underscoring that idea so yesterday
kamal harris in the middle of a
oppressor
she literally said that she would be
leading a harris administration
they're not saying the quiet part out
loud here is kamala harris i mean get a
get a food taster joe
a harris administration together with
joe biden
joe biden who's running for president
again then biden yesterday botched it
himself he called it a harris biden
administration as opposed to a
biden-harris administration
harris pride administration is going to
relaunch that effort and keep pushing
further to make it easier for military
spouses and veterans
to find meaningful careers to ensure
teachers know how to support military
children in their classrooms now that
harrisburg administration is the threat
there is
not a survivor so that is trump's case
right trump's case is twofold one that
he's unhealthy so he can't handle the
job but more importantly if he's
unhealthy kamala harris ends up
being president and unfortunately for
biden he the more he is out in public
and this is why they're minimizing his
public appearances
so i understand again the the kind of
thematic attempt by trump to get out
there a lot so that he can show that joe
biden is not as lively and with it and
then maybe he's unhealthy
i get all of that i do i don't think
trump needs to do that i think trump
should go to the basement and he should
let joe biden
have to make public appearances because
every time he makes a public appearance
it gets more and more desperate
so yesterday joe biden was speaking at
some sort of forum for latinos
or as the democrats and the woke call
them latinx which
by the way is a descriptor no latino or
hispanic person i've ever heard of
actually uses for themselves
it is not in fact a popular term except
among social justice warriors who
believe that they
get to name latino and hispanic people
what they want to name him
joe biden came out at this event playing
despacito
on his phone this is about as awk
remember that time
when donald trump put out a tweet in the
middle of the 2016 campaign
it was just a picture of him on his
plane eating a taco bowl and he was like
i love mexicans taco bell and
everybody's like what now
and it was really really funny and
ridiculous joe biden just one-upped him
here's an awkward old man playing
desposito
i just have one thing to say
they're
oh my god there you go
i'll tell you what if i had the talent
of any one of these people i'd be
i'd be elected president by acclimation
you know if i had the talent of any one
of these i don't know what i'm listening
to my hearing aid is low and his ammo
also who are these people i'm talking
about the talent of anyone are we
talking about
mexicans or guatemala joe biden
high energy individual also again
maybe i'm not sure this is all baked
into the cake maybe it is maybe joe
biden senility is baked into the cake
but maybe not right because every time
he goes out in public he babbles
nonsensically like an idiot
as i've said before the presidential
debates will be something to behold
donald trump has said he's not going to
prep for it which again is idiotic you
have to prep for your debate
you have to prep for your debate it
matters this is one of the only debates
that matters the bar is so low for joe
biden that if he doesn't physically fall
on his face and start drooling oatmeal
bits then he will probably be declared
the winner
by the media so that means that donald
trump actually has to show up so not
prepping for it is really dumb but
is it all baked into the cake that
people realize just how badly joe biden
has degraded
here was joe biden babbling yesterday
about quartermasters what in the world
is going on in this clip
because if you could take care if you
were a quartermaster
you can sure in health take care of
running a you know
department store uh thing you know were
in the second floor of the ladies
department you know what i mean
your future presidents of the united
states verl
young with it if you're the
quartermaster of the ladies department
and
the revolutionary war and they were
quartering troops in your in your house
with corn pop and his individuals you
shouldn't be going down anything around
yeah cream of wheat
denny's early bird dinner okay well done
also uh yesterday joe biden struggled to
remember barack obama's name which is
weird because the only person who has
ever
made joe biden's queer worth a damn is
the man named barack obama here it was
yesterday
when we hit the recession
the president at president obama asked
me
to see if i could convince my republican
friends to join us
in yeah that's awkward that's awkward by
the way biden's campaign manager was
again asked as a different campaign
manager was asked yesterday
if biden uses a teleprompter during
interviews and again refuse stands for
the question
because the answer is yes of course he
uses a teleprompter during interviews
because he is not
cogent he is not cognizant he is not
with it okay
here like this is the easiest question
in the world honestly they should have
just put
no in this lady's teleprompter how do
you respond to the criticism that has
uh uh we've seen this all over about the
vice president using a teleprompter
during some of these interviews
oh well i mean first of all i i would
say
very clearly the vice president uses the
teleprompter uh on occasion
you see it as giving a speech but he is
also out there every day
taking questions from reporters you're
seeing that today he's in florida
uh and we'll continue to take questions
he's take i think he took questions
four or five times uh out on the stump
and out of his travel last week no he is
not taking questions he's running away
from questions
okay so at this point trump has two
hopes one the democrats continue to tie
themselves to the radical left
two everybody sort of realizes that joe
biden is not completely with it
speaking of the radical left what is not
canceled these days seriously
we are canceling all the things there
are no more things to to be canceled i
feel like
i feel like we're going to have to live
basically in a vacuum
we're all going to be ejected into space
where there's nothing left to be
canceled
they're not even atoms left to be
canceled we're just going to be in a
complete vacuum
and that's that's the real way to get
woke because we'll all be dead but at
least we'll be floating in a vacuum
that'll be exciting stuff vox has a
piece vox
the same people who proposed that there
was a land bridge between the west bank
and the gaza strip
the geniuses over at vox they have a
piece yesterday by nick sloane and
charlie harding here is the title
how beethoven's fifth symphony put the
classism in classical music
so now beethoven's fifth symphony
is racist and classist now to realize
how stupid this was you have to you have
to understand that beethoven
was a pretty thoroughbred secular
humanist uh that beethoven specifically
rejected
imperialism of any sort and he famously
dedicated the third symphony
to napoleon bonaparte but then ripped
off the cover page when
napoleon bonaparte declared himself
emperor but apparently that's not good
enough
beethoven is now cancelled to many
beethoven's most famous work is a symbol
of exclusion and elitism in classical
music as vox.com
beethoven's fifth symphony starts with
an anguished opening theme dun dun dun
dun
and ends with a glorious major key
melody since it's 1808 premiere
audiences have interpreted that
progression from struggle to victory as
a metaphor for beethoven's personal
resilience in the face of his oncoming
deafness
or rather that's long been the popular
read among wealthy white men
who embraced beethoven and turned his
symphony into a symbol
of their superiority and importance what
the
f what in the f i've never heard this
before like seriously i've never heard
this
in any context as a classical musician
i've played violin since i was five
years old okay i played the beethoven
violin concerto
i have i've played beethoven's romances
like i'm big beethoven fan
i'm quite familiar with the classical
repertoire
no one no one is like you know what
beethoven's fifth simpsonny
it happened because he's white because
he's a white man
but vox cancels beethoven why for uh
this is incredible
that's longer than the popular read
among wealthy white men who embraced
beethoven and turned his symphony into a
symbol
of their own superiority and importance
for others women
lgbtq plus people people of color
beethoven's symphony
may be predominantly a reminder of
classical music's history of exclusion
and elitism
one new york city classical music fan
wrote in the 1840s for example
that he wished that all women shall be
gagged by officers duly licensed for the
purpose before they're allowed to enter
a concert room oh wow you cited a rando
from the 1840s who thought that women
talk too much at classical concerts
boom owned beethoven roll over beethoven
you're done
what is it so apparently
trans people and questioning people or
queer people and bisexual people
are particularly off put by the fifth
symphony
which is very very strange that's a very
strange thing to
to intuit fox i didn't see that one
coming i'll be honest with you i've seen
a lot of these cancellations coming
canceling the fifth symphony because
trans women
are excluded by a piece written and
premiered in 1808.
that's a new one for me i'll i'll admit
i didn't points for creativity
today some aspects of classical culture
are still policing who's in
and who's out and much of it started
with beethoven's fifth when you walk
into a standard concert hall there's an
established set of conventions in
etiquette don't cough don't cheer
dress appropriately that's more about
demonstrating belonging than
appreciating the music
tell me more people who have never been
to a classical concert or apparently
don't appreciate classical music hey
there are certain conventions
that are appropriate for the classical
music hall because people would like to
hear the music they are not rock
concerts
and now it wasn't always like this they
were sort of performed like rock
concerts when they were written
but over time there's been a classical
canon it's been true with great awe and
reverence because these are in fact the
pinnacles
of western creativity and it's not going
to get better than beethoven
it just is not but like
those conventions include things like
don't clap between movements
okay like they're movements to
symphonies and usually symphony has four
movements
so when you get to the the end of each
movement you don't clap
after the first movement of beethoven's
fifth you clap at the very end of the
symphony is that because of racism or
classism
the vox got together with the new york
philharmonic
and broke down the music and meaning of
this inescapable work of music we have
we must ask how beethoven symphony was
transformed from symbol of triumph and
freedom
into a symbol of exclusion elitism and
gatekeeping everything we love to hate
about classical
music today how did the meaning of the
symphony gets so twisted
for classical music critic james bennett
ii beethoven's popularity and centrality
and classical culture is part of the
problem
as you perpetuate the idea that the
giants of the muse of the music all look
the same
it conveys to the other that there is
not a stake in that music for them he
says okay i hate this
garbage so much i can't even explain how
much i hate this garbage the notion
that you can only appreciate somebody
else's work if you look like them
is the most tribal bullcrap i have ever
heard in my entire life
as a jew there are a few great classical
jewish composers
right mendelssohn was jewish and felix
mendelson was jewish so
psalms was jewish bizet was jewish
that's pretty much it i mean there are a
few others
you know whose music i like more than
that brahms not jewish beethoven not
jewish mozart not jewish bach not jewish
the the the very essence of thinking as
a rational human being
is deciding what you do and do not like
based on things other than tribal
affinity
and yet now we are being told that
because beethoven was white he is
inherently canceled because white people
might take some sort of reverence from
the fact that he was white
now it's weird about this is these exact
same people will say you know what we
need we need more black
composers who are given their proper due
because that will make black people feel
good about themselves
well you can't have it both ways either
you should say that great music should
be appreciated for being great music
and that we should appreciate duke
ellington because duke ellington was a
fabulous musician
rather than because duke ellington was
black and we should appreciate beethoven
because he was a fabulous musician
rather than because he was white or you
have to make the claim that we should
appreciate duke ellington for his
blackness and beethoven for his
whiteness but you can't have it both
ways
but this is the way that the left would
like it new york philharmonic
clarinetist anthony mcgill one of the
few black musicians in the ensemble
agrees that beethoven's inescapability
makes classical music appear
monolithic and stifling he likens the
inescapability of the fifth symphony to
a wall
between classical music and new diverse
audiences if you pretend like there's no
other music out there that beethoven is
the greatest music that will ever matter
says miguel then orchestras will
alienate
new listeners since we're not promoting
any of the composers alive today that
are trying to become the beethovens of
their day
okay let me just point out none of the
people trying to become beethoven are
beethoven
the new york times recently put out this
long piece including a bunch of little
snippets of modern classical music
i tried man i tried i listened to every
single one
of those little snippets and for the
most part they sucked they are not
listenable
that doesn't mean that the composers
don't know more about music composition
than i do i am sure they do
it doesn't mean that there aren't a
small cadre of people who appreciate
that i'm sure there are
but that in a very big cadre of people
and if you are making the claim
that the the modern composers of the
philip glasses of today
and though that those composers are on
the level of beethoven yeah shove it
and that oh we have to stop talking
about how beethoven is great because it
might convince people that modern
composers aren't good
it should convince people modern
composers aren't good modern composers
are not that good
in 200 years nobody is going to be
listening to any of the people on that
modern composers list from the new york
times and that's just in the classical
field
i get ripped up and down for my elitism
because i say beethoven is better than
cardi b
which is inherently obvious to anyone
with functioning prefrontal cortex
i'm sorry if it's offensive to you that
i think that brahms is better than
eminem
but brahms is better than eminem
the the very destruction of art in the
name of wokeness is just it's despicable
it's despicable so well done vox going
after beethoven beethoven is now
cancelled just
really let's cancel all the good things
all of them all the things that could
possibly tie us together music is
cancelled sports is canceled movies are
canceled
again i i'm kind of eager about this
i'll be honest with you we're moving
over to nashville and one of the things
that we plan on doing
is engaging far more in the culture wars
what i mean by that is not just
calling out stuff that we don't like
culturally but actually producing
cultural content we're intending on
doing this
so thank you to the left for canceling
everything that is good fun and
interesting about human life because
you've opened up a market for us
and we look forward to filling it
alrighty we'll be back here later today
for two additional hours
of content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowski our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
president trump introduces peace deals
with nine
new middle eastern countries kanye west
calls himself the new moses
and the foolish things of this world
confound the wise
check it out on the michael knowles show